our real food series continues this
morning with a fresh look at a dish that
says Hawaiian as the hula po ke uses
seasoned chunks of raw fish like tuna or
salmon it's long been an island mainstay
for locals and tourists now the dish is
showing up on more menus across the
country but the po ke boom is raising
concerns in the food industry about the
impact on the overall fish supply John
Blackstone traveled to Paradise to
understand polkas appeal millions of
tourists visit Hawaii each year seeking
Sun and sea breezes increasingly they
also come for poking wonderful really
good that's good the flavor packed
concoction of raw fish is an essential
part of the diet for Hawaiians like
Reijo how long you been eating pokin my
light lately however he's seen poke a
transform they've all been very creative
in thinking of different ways of making
at Merriman's restaurant on kauai spyfu
beach and then we have a touch of sesame
oil also that we're just gonna kind of
drizzle in there chef mark Arriola is a
poke a perfectionist hmm good man you're
done chef I've made a few of these sup
man
yes bouquet has risen in prominence
polka places are popping up across the
country in Illinois Zach Friedlander is
hoping to take his aloha poke a company
nationwide by the end of the year
opening roughly a dozen more locations
it's a healthier way to eat it's it's
revolutionising the way people eat fast
food the way people look at fast food
the fact that polka is making it big so
far from home make some people here in
Hawaii proud but others find it just a
little bit fishy I've looked at some of
the menus and I've looked at some of the
things and we're not we don't throw
pineapple and bananas and all kinds of
I've seen some weird variations of stuff
where I'm like what is that but what
also worries chef areola is that the new
popularity of bouquet could lead to
overfishing a 2016 study by the UN
reported that nearly 90% of fish stocks
are fully fished or over fished even in
Hawaii Arriola says fishermen can't
always meet demand that's scary because
there's no guy living under the water
they can say oh there's plenty of fish
we're good you know you don't know until
they just don't they don't show up
anymore I don't necessarily think that
we're gonna put a dent in the fishing
industry with the amount of restaurants
for opening the Aloha pogue a company
like many others says it uses
sustainable suppliers and methods to
make sure the fish and the business
stick around for a long time a lot of
people have kind of gone back and forth
is this a fad is this gonna just come
right out and I'm firm believer that
book is here to stay still vacationers
jennie-o and jasonlew who can get polka
at home in California say it's just not
the same as having it in Hawaii
the quality's much better
a better price too that counts as well
yes and you're in Hawaii and you're in
Hawaii
truth is palm trees and sea breezes may
just make everything taste better for
CBS this morning Jon blacksmith Kauai I
[Music]
don't know I don't know everything in
Hawaii does taste I mean it's fish it's
delicious
maybe was the pineapple that he did the
banana